hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday november 1st
2021 what's going on oh yeah
holy [ __ ] people
it's november 1st this is like election
week you know for people who pay
attention to politics
this you know
it was almost a year ago
got rid of that orange racist
in favor of a warmonger with dementia
i think they're a combined 236 years old
or something um
who knows people who who who even knows
why what's going on why are my [ __ ]
headphones so quietly but the volume
appears to be so loud
i don't know what it is who knows who
the hell knows anyway
it's nice to be here good to talk to you
it's super tuesday tomorrow in the local
election for your managerial
gubernatorial
uh lame duck
when will that be considered offensive
he's a lame duck candidate i don't think
talking about a wounded bird is the
proper way
try and describe the human being i mean
don't we have enough advantages over
ducks
isn't it bad enough
that the french
don't let their models eat while they
force feed these [ __ ] birds
so the managers the fat [ __ ] managers of
those skinny models can eat the fat duck
in front of the quivering model isn't
that enough
do we have to say lame duck
why can't we just say
not elected not re-elected or not not
seeking i will not seek
nor will i seek
i do not desire nor will i seek another
term
i'm lbj i'm getting the [ __ ] out of here
you enjoy
your war
with the vietnamese people
um
anyway i hope you guys had a nice
weekend i had a great weekend you know
because it was halloween
yesterday dooba dooby doo is the
beginning of the holiday
seasons and mom and dad are taking their
kids out to go trick-or-treating
man i heard some [ __ ] crazy names
when i was out there
somebody called their kid army i swear
to god
leah where's army
you called your kid army
what i support the troops
um
army yeah i mean just i mean
i mean bill bob joe that's just [ __ ]
eons ago i feel like my name at this
point
like pretty soon people are gonna know
just by hearing my name my first name
being bill they're gonna be like oh yeah
that guy's like 70 right
like it's like ebenezer
oh let me look that up i gotta see
how popular is the name bill let's see
if i'm still hanging in there
how popular
is the name like you know what name i
think's going away like doug
you know doug i think that's going most
viewed bills
no how popular is
the name
bill
boy name bill trends popularity of bills
okay
it [ __ ]
there was nobody 1880s it was very few
1898 all of a sudden around world war
one
everybody right through world
oh yeah right through world war ii man
it just kept going up and up and up like
it was never going to come back down
again
and then it plummeted in the 50s
it came back in the 60s and oh my god
it just what
it just [ __ ] dropped off the it
dropped off the charts
in 1880
it was a you know like 50 kids were
named bill i can't believe that
william shakespeare you know
that wasn't enough well he was before
that right
wow it's after like 1988
looks like in the mid 90s it just died
the greatest number of people who were
given that name is 1947 when
4680 people in the u.s were given the
name bill
those people are now 74 years old
so wait
okay here we go here's a quote i never
hear anyone anyone say the name bill
anymore except with friends and family
no one in their 20s or 30s is named bill
just baby boomers so i guess guys named
bill
are a rare thing nowadays
long live
the bill that was february 21st my
dragon granddad is called william
is but called bill i love him
that was in 2008. all right three
neutral those those were the positive
comments
three neutral comments i love the name
bill i'm 12 and i'm naming my baby this
when i have one lol
jesus that person got knocked up pretty
young that must be mississippi my name
is i'm kidding i can't do that please
don't do that bill my name is bill and i
love it it's a strong intelligent name
that can age with you that was in 2009
my brother-in-law is bill i find it
strange that my in-laws did that because
people assume it is short for william
but it's not
okay what do you think about the name
bill
what's the question all right i i have a
[ __ ] old name i'm old and my name
is out of style
all right well i guess you know
i'm just a bill yes i'm only a bill
and nobody wants to do it no more
um
anyway uh
yeah so i took my kiddo out me and my
wife took my uh our daughter out
for halloween
and we had a blast and she met up with
some kids
you know
from the neighborhood they all went out
together and you know it was fun you
know some houses weren't participating
some people had like pipes these like
you know the plastic piping whatever the
[ __ ] you call it
pcp piping when it bvc whatever the [ __ ]
you call it
they were dropping the candy down and
none of the kids could get it down it
would just fall into the driveway it was
kind of funny
but i get it no one wants to breathe on
anybody i don't even know why i don't
even know anymore but like like half the
houses weren't even [ __ ]
participating
which was kind of a bummer
you know because i was telling my
daughter last night i was going like we
are gonna go to a million million houses
gonna fill up that little uh
bucket of yours we did pretty good we
filled it up three quarters of the way
but um
you know i did the whole thing i made
pumpkin bread
we went to a pumpkin patch with a corn
maze and a friggin tractor ride
you know i carved a pumpkin
i took the seeds out
i shelled the seeds
by hand holy [ __ ] i never did that i
used to just make them whole
but then i was just like oh wait you're
supposed to shell these things or you
can you know when they put them on your
salad they're shelled
so i don't know i just kind of got
involved in that
and like the rain man i couldn't stop
doing it
and uh when i finally stopped like
trying to like shell all the seeds you
get from one pumpkin
um holy [ __ ]
my back was killing me because i did
legs the other day at the gym and i was
thinking like you know
all the ego weightlifting exercises i
always try to increase my weight
but
i never do
i'm always yawning on the podcast i'm
sorry guys i either do it early in the
morning or late at night the kids either
have to not be up yet or they've already
gone to sleep um
so with legs i never did it so i did
like uh
we used you know
we used to call it pyramids
pyramid sets you know you do 10 8642
you know increasing the weight i did
that on the squat machine and uh jesus
christ i don't know what it feels like
to play an nfl game but this is the
closest i ever want to feel so
i'm going to take an
salt bath
tonight after
after the podcast here so
anyway let's talk a little nfl football
here
[Music]
oh wait i gotta keep talking about
halloween so we went around in the
neighborhood that's what i was hearing
like
i heard this woman just going like
we need an adult leader and we need a
kid leader we got to do this for the
army tell leo to tell
[ __ ] you know
well some other weird name that began
with the t and i was just listening to
these names that made me think like what
in the [ __ ]
what are those names
then i was just thinking when i grew
when i grew up there was like
there was a bunch of bills there were
jasons
i bet let me see doug doug must have
fell off
let me see here
how popular
is the name doug
douglas has been in a free-fall decline
since 1990. i i called it dropping
almost 400 positions
on the charts
in 20 years
no longer in vogue people are beginning
to consider this name outdated and a
little boring
it's still an interesting choice for
scottish american parents
or those who appreciate
the mystery of a dark stream
the hell does that mean
let me see what is what's the meaning of
the name doug
name doug
meaning
doug
it means she knows what
no
in english baby names the meaning of the
name doug is dark water
in the 17th century this name was
as popular for girls as for boys and
scottish baby names the meaning of the
name doug is from the gaelic
i don't know how to say d-u-b-h-g-l-a-s
meaning dark water dark stream or from
the dark river
oh what does that mean like
you knocked up some chicken then you
realize she was a psycho so then you
named the kid
dark river i don't know
american baby name meanings in american
baby names the meaning of the name doug
is from the gaelic meaning dark water
yeah dark water dark stream
i don't know who gives a [ __ ] bill all
right so we had a great time and there's
nothing better there's nothing better
than taking a kid out on halloween
seeing how excited they get every house
she'd be like oh dad look i got a
starburst
[Laughter]
oh damn look what i got
what is that what is that
and some of the candy i didn't even know
somebody was giving out hundred thousand
dollar bars i was like wow
and a couple of people were giving out
almond joys which have coconut which is
very a very divisive
ingredient
when it comes to uh candy bars me
personally
you know
i draw the line at nougat i [ __ ] hate
nougat
i don't know what it is it's [ __ ]
gross it's filler it's the coleslaw
of of of candy fillers i not you know
three musketeers terrible
terrible [ __ ] candy bar
um
which pound for pound i feel i mean it's
all nougat it's chocolate wrapped
[ __ ] nougat
ted nougat
that's that would be fat ted nugent
um all right so poo by the way i saw a
clip
a buddy of mine got
of him playing uh cat scratch fever
just playing the riff with chris
leighton and jimmy vaughn
and holy shield
ted nugent can still [ __ ] play my god
i mean everybody sounded great but his
[ __ ]
passion he was amazing um
all right let's get on to i've been why
i watched the world series
i watched since game two on
specifically
because it annoyed me that um some
people on sports talk radio were saying
that houston versus atlanta
sorry i figured if i just get the yawn
out of me it would stop
houston versus atlanta was a ratings
nightmare
and they were blaming the cities and
saying the cities are boring and blah
blah blah houston and atlanta are not
boring
you can have a great great [ __ ] time
in both of those cities those cities are
the antithesis of being boring right
the problem is not the cities it's the
way the mlb
runs their [ __ ] league
with the luxury tax they just made a
halves and have nuts that's basically it
you know and not to mention that i
remember when they had the subway series
and was the yankees against the mets
they thought the whole [ __ ] baseball
community was going to give a [ __ ]
nobody cared except people in new york
so who the [ __ ] knows so anyway i'm like
you know i'm so [ __ ] sick of them
[ __ ] on these
so-called
b-level cities
that i am not going to um
you know i'm going to watch this goddamn
series so
i've been watching it and um
the braves bullpen was basically saving
their bacon and uh
game three and four and they only got a
couple
innings out of their starting pitchers
and then their their
bullpen
pitched a ton of innings but got him
through it and
dusty baker
switched up the lineup tonight
for what could have been the clincher
for the braves
and i don't understand how switching up
the lineup other than if you're more at
the top of the order you're going to
possibly get an extra at bat than
somebody batting you know fifth on down
depending on how the other team pitched
and how many hits they let up
um
well i guess no matter what you're going
to because you're at the top of the
order but um
they uh they put a thumping on him nine
to five
in one game five
and possibly
just blew the [ __ ] series
i don't know why there was something
about tonight it just felt like
that the braves had to win it
and they started the game i think it's
because it was the game clincher and
they started it with the grand slam in
the first inning
in the first inning they hit a grand
slam
and you got to think you know if you're
up three games to one
okay and in game five
all right you shut down the other team
and then you go out there and load them
up and hit a grand slam
the crowd's going crazy this series is
over
but then to not score any more runs for
like another [ __ ] i don't know four
or five innings and the other team just
chips away at it and all of a sudden
you're down one
and then you have you know you tack on
another couple next thing you know
you're down four
and the tomahawk chop you know
sounds like there's only three people
doing it at this point i just feel like
it was a really demoralizing loss
for the braves and now they have to go
into houston and try to win one they
gotta split
you know game six is uh tuesday night
and uh i gotta be honest with you
i don't think they're gonna do it
and this whole series i didn't know who
to root for
you know i wanted to root for the braves
because i always liked watching the
braves
when i was a kid when we first got basic
cable
and they had uh bob horner and you know
glenn hubbard and dale murphy
i used to [ __ ] love watching because
i love watching national league baseball
back when they used to play and was at
fulton county stadium
and they didn't do the tomahawk chop
back then it's just the tomahawk chop
thing it's just so [ __ ]
you know overtly ignorant
you know and then i love that wow
um
i used to do a joke in my act they're
doing like you know the tomahawk chop oh
doing that
i'd be like you know that that would be
like if the germans won world war ii
and then like you know
at sporting events they would chant oh
eve
or eve
um
you know i don't know but i think the
south i don't know they get like a bad
rap for that [ __ ]
as far as like
i think they're a convenient scapegoat
for [ __ ] northern whites
you know and i really think that like if
northern whites treat southern whites
better after the civil war this is the
theory i have
you know because i was watching that
[ __ ] and i was you know
hanging with somebody
of color
that was in atlanta i go can you believe
they still do this [ __ ]
i just thought it was funny as a
comedian too where i'm sitting there
going like you know
if i do like a transgender joke
you know i i could get in a lot of
trouble but like
but i could do the tomahawk chop and
that's okay
[Laughter]
i just don't know where the line is
anymore
so um
i was talking to this person and she was
like uh
i go can you believe that they're doing
that
and she goes yeah i live there she goes
they know what they're doing
they don't care
i was like you didn't like live in
atlanta she goes i hated it
i hated it
i wanted to get the [ __ ] out of it which
is funny to me because i remember a long
time ago
a buddy of mine
got into a debate with a guy on the
radio
where he was saying he didn't like you
know
something about atlanta and this guy was
going to atlanta he goes the other white
guy was like it's a bastion of liberal
ideology that's what he said which is
[ __ ] hilarious
because that's that classic thing it's
like i went down there as a white guy
they they treated me
great so um
i don't know i was kind of thinking i'm
like why didn't they do that why do they
do that with the [ __ ] confederate
flag and be like nah that has nothing to
do with that it means this and that time
like shopping
and i'm thinking like all right
it's very easy to be like yeah because
they're all [ __ ] morons down there
and i can go neal young on this [ __ ]
right and [ __ ] act like you know
ignorant white people are only down
there i don't know if you really trace
it back if you see how bad northern
white's treated
southern whites
you know because they were [ __ ]
pissed at them
for trying to secede from the union and
we were at war with one another i think
if we were a little more empathetic
towards them
you know and haven't tried to make them
feel less than here's my theory do you
think if northern whites
you know had not talked down to southern
whites
since the civil war right up until like
right now
would they be this is my question would
they be more empathetic
uh
because it is like totally okay
maybe that's their thought well it's
okay for some talk show host or some
stand-up comedian like me to [ __ ] all
over us
and not only do you not get in trouble
you get applauded for it
you know then why should i show [ __ ]
empathy for other people
other groups
i have no idea
i have no idea but like i was just
actually thinking you know if the
germans won
and then you could have like berlin
talking to frankfurt like looking down
on them
you know like
you shouldn't be doing the oe
chop
that's a soccer match
you know
because i think there is that thing
especially you know being out here in
hollywood all these [ __ ] liberal
[ __ ]
who pat themselves on the back that
they'll say like native american and
then then that sort of
you know they're even
with history at that point
so i don't say indian i say native
americans so like yeah
so i guess it's cool that my
house in my infinity pool is
on top of your murdered
ancestors i'm so concerned
by using the proper terminology and like
the three like native americans that
i've actually met you know
because you don't run into them that
often at least in my world i don't said
they actually preferred to be called
indian and that native american was some
[ __ ] white people came up with
so i didn't i was like really i didn't
know you know
so you'd rather be called that they were
like yeah at least these three guys that
i've talked to said that so
then i'm thinking like so what's the
philosophy there
like
probably ideally
i would know the name of your tribe but
if i'm not going to take the time to
learn that then why don't you just call
me the dumbass name that you thought i
was
you know or your ancestors thought i was
or something i don't know what i don't
know what the [ __ ] you know
logic of that [ __ ] is but anyway it's
just something like i you know because i
i'm looking at the [ __ ] astros i'm
all over the map here i'm looking at the
asteroids i'm like how the [ __ ] can i
root for these guys all right
as a patriots fan i can't [ __ ] root
for them because they're not getting the
[ __ ] that they [ __ ] you know
like tonight was the first time i kind
of heard a few people before the game
talking about
you know the whole scandal
and blah blah blah and all that that
[ __ ] that they went through but it's
like at the end of the day it's like
dude they still count that thing
they still count that thing
and uh as a patriots fan the [ __ ]
trumped up horseshit [ __ ] charges
against my team
throughout
what the [ __ ] they did all still sticks
i still have people come up to me going
yeah you tape the rams practice it's
like we never did that
it was [ __ ] [ __ ] it was
completely debunked espn ran with the
story and they did their detraction on
their twitter at like two in the morning
after [ __ ] 15 years of saying it
happened
and then the patriots gave them a
sarcastic thank you
um
but the astros can [ __ ] shake off
[Music]
you know
having a camera filming the [ __ ]
signs it's just i don't know i don't
know how the [ __ ] i don't know how it
works but anyways it's been a great
series
and uh i gotta tell you something that
uh altuve guy is just [ __ ]
that guy's the [ __ ] he's just a [ __ ]
it's been a great series but i gotta be
honest man i
think
that that [ __ ] series is over
um
i think the braves have one last burst
of energy in them
and if if the astros survive that
the beginning of the game
they go up a couple of [ __ ] runs the
astros it's they're gonna lose six and
seven it's gonna be over
and um if you think those people eat in
houston now
wait till they actually win a legitimate
world series
because you know those tubbies down
there they're dying for that to happen
so they can tell everybody to shut the
[ __ ] up
you know uh but i gotta be honest with
you
all the way through this i've supported
the astros
going like well look you know they you
know they finally brought a gun to a
gunfight
they had to sit back all those years not
have the money to win a world series and
watch teams like my team have roided up
free agents and [ __ ] win the goddamn
thing so why can't they bang on a
[ __ ] trash can to try to level it out
um
who knows so what do you guys think of
that theory
you
know about southern white people i mean
i think northern white people should be
[ __ ] i mean i think people in general
should just treat each other with
respect but this whole [ __ ] idea i
ideology or whatever the [ __ ] word is
uh first of all that racism is only in
the south
and in boston massachusetts
that was like that you know
um
is [ __ ] it's unfortunately
everywhere but i i really think that uh
i don't know i have no idea there's
nothing behind this i just thought i was
just i was just watching the game going
why would you just be that [ __ ]
overtly
disrespectful why why why do that
and then i thought about it just going
well look at the level disrespect that
they get
after a while you get a chip on your
shoulder and you're like you know what
you're saying [ __ ] me well then [ __ ]
everybody else
maybe that's why i don't know why
just trying to get my head around why
you would [ __ ] do that
[Laughter]
[Music]
um i don't know anyway
but you know what i do know i'm not
gonna solve it sitting here talking to
myself
all right um anyway
let's plow ahead here let's talk uh
let's do a little advertising little ad
reads here simply
safe
you know if you've ever wanted to make
your home feel safer there's no better
time than right now this week our
friends at simply safe
are giving the monday morning podcast
listeners 40
off
their award-winning security system
we love simply safe because it has
everything you need to make your home
safe indoor and outdoor cameras
comprehensive sensors
all monitored around the clock by
trained professionals
who send help the instant you need it
you know what i learned today most
burglaries happen during the day
yeah they don't wanna they don't wanna
be there when you're home then they
gotta [ __ ] you know they gotta
they gotta do some violent [ __ ] you know
what i mean i don't know what to turn
tail and run and you see their face
they're gonna get caught so they try to
do it while you're at work
well you're at work man you gotta you
gotta go work to make the money to pay
for your place but who can watch it when
you're at work
the men and women at simply safe
all right you can easily customize a
system
for your home online in minutes and even
get free custom recommendations from
simply safe these are simply safes
biggest discounts of the year you can
get a complete home security system
starting at just over one hundred
dollars there are no long-term contracts
or commitments it's really easy it's a
really easy way to start feeling a bit
more peace of mind take advantage of the
simply safe holiday sale get forty
percent off your new home security
system by visiting simply safe dot com
slash bur again that's s i m p l i s a f
e
dot com slash burr for forty percent off
your entire system hurry this offer will
end soon
yeah i learned a number of those things
i heard you know burglars they break in
they want to get in and get the [ __ ] out
so what they usually do is they head for
the master bedroom they grab whatever
they can [ __ ] grab and then they run
out before the cops can get there and
you can have it all on film
with simply safe
um
helix everybody
helix
helix has a sleep quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be the perfect way
for the way you
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have a soft
medium and firm mattress mattress great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
uh your sweaty bastard masters uh
masters mattress great for spinal
alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers they got one for the big boys
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you re that you're rematched to
that you're matched to
sorry it was all one word there and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to the mattress store again helix is
awesome but you don't need to take my
word for it
all right helix was awarded the number
one best overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine
helix has been recommended by multiple
leading chiropractors and doctors of
sleep medicine as a go-to solution for
improving sleep just go to
helixsleep.com take the two-minute quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10-year
warranty
and you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free gross they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but you
will
helix even has financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at
helixsleep.com that's healingsleep.com
for up to 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows all right look who
it is everybody it's candid
smile but do you're on candid camera
candid there's a specialist there's a
specialist for just about everything
right when your car breaks down you go
to a mechanic when there's a problem
with your shower you call a promo
plumber right when there's a pandemic
yeah talk to your friend
uh so when you want to get to your on
so when you want to get your uneven
crooked teeth fixed you see an
orthodontist they're the specialists
and that's what sets candidate candid
the invisible comfortable and removable
aligners above the rest i can't read
tonight uh while poorly reviewed or
insanely priced clear aligner companies
use general dentists candid only worths
works with orthodontists with canon
candid the same orthodontist who created
your plan is with you from start to
finish so you never have to wonder how
you're doing your treatment is
prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
who's an expert in tooth movement you
can book an appointment at a candid
studio near you or do everything from
the comfort and convenience of your own
home the average can
candid treatment is just six months
and you'll start seeing results way
before them and it costs thousands less
than traditional braces
um i did this [ __ ] dude i love you know
my teeth were always straight up top but
on the bottom i had a couple of [ __ ]
you know a couple of teeth that needed
to get their mind right if you know what
i mean
um
and with your liner treatment you'll get
candid teeth whitening for free candid
can help you get the straighter
brightest smile you've always wanted
right now you can save 75
dollars on your candid starter kit when
you get started from home or you can
book an appointment at a candid studio
near you today go to
candidco.com use the code bird that's
candidco.com
codebird take advantage of this limited
time offer to save 75 dollars on your
starter kit
candid co charlie oscar dot com slash
birth capital co by the way candid
capital co dot com
code
burr do i got the right thing do i have
the right there we go all right let's do
the reads here for this week
sorry people
i try i try my best here cigars for
warriors hey billy [ __ ] tits
heard you were going to throw out your
cigars
instead of tossing i did i'm not going
to throw i thought i was going to throw
them out i was [ __ ] mad at myself
instead of just tossing them
here is an organization that sends
cigars to folks deployed overseas
worth looking into if you haven't tossed
them yet just need to drop them off at a
local
a location near
you or ship them
it's called cigarsforwarriors.org
sounds like a [ __ ] scam to me for
people to get
you know skim the great cigars and then
send the troops [ __ ] dutch masters
but all right
cigarsforwarriors.org if you're like me
and you're thinking of taking all your
cigars and throwing them down the
[ __ ] trash
you can go to let me let me click on
this let me see cigars
for warriors
so what does that mean they only give
them to the people on the front lines
look at this
there's a bunch of [ __ ] guy a bunch
of troops smoking cigars
all right i have to do this
who can turn the world on with his old
cigars
who can send some [ __ ] sticks
to the troops in the middle east well
it's you bill and you should know it
with each little stokey and cigar you
show it send your [ __ ] [ __ ]
to cigars for warriors sorry cigars for
warriors everybody there you go
or you just buy a box and send it over
there all right capitol hill bill i'm
just a bill hey bill i'm a climate
geologist for over 20 years of field
work research and five published books
all right yeah i know you wrote that
sentence i don't know if any of that's
true i'm a geologist first and foremost
but i study the macro effects on climate
of climate on earth
do i really want to read the rest of
this
the current climate crisis discourse has
been dangerously hijacked by
corporations who are looking to profit
from it i will try and be brief and
provide clear examples congress is about
to pass a huge spending bill that's
almost two trillion dollars and a
significant portion of the bill's
spending is meant to fight against
climate change the problem is that most
of the money is going to subsidy areas
of oil companies and other groups that
have no identify identifiable role in
meaningful change why did they do this
why would they do that
i just i swear to god just is it really
just greed
self-preservation so they get reelected
i don't know no mention of
uh tapering back on resources or
creating standards to reduce the need
for a new iphone chargers every year for
reasons i cannot explain there's been a
push to get away from nuclear power this
makes absolutely no sense every time a
plant gets shut down we rely more on
fossil fuels in the last year there's
been huge moves by members of the
european union and the us government to
stifle nuclear power research and
innovation
so like oil companies the blue blood
families from like the 1800s they've
really just been running [ __ ] for the
better part of a century and a half
the u.s oil prices this year have gone
completely backwards instead of
maintaining our own oil production that
can be overseen environmentally
regulated and of course more beneficial
to the u.s economy we're now relying
even more on oil from overseas and
empowering saudi arabia and russia with
the fate of our resources i'm not an
economist but i can confirm that over
the last 80 years there's been a
positive correlation between the
low-cost
reliability energy and quality of life
for lower income brackets
puerto rico is a great example of this
their quality of life has vastly
improved with reliable energy despite
this u s politicians have been lobbying
to shut down domestic energy operations
for no discernible reason
other than the people that put them in
office told them to
imagine a career politician from new
york having strong feelings about where
puerto rico gets their energies it's so
[ __ ] evil nothing adds up with any of
this i appreciate you mentioning all the
flat screens that end up in the ocean
yeah well i think like
here's my positive spin on that
is you can sit there and [ __ ] about
these [ __ ] greedy
politicians and these corrupt
corporations
or
you can do something in your personal
the only way to do it is to combat it
with your own life
and
you know
as i'm sitting there bitching about you
know liberals the way they treat
southerners maybe making them more
close-minded i don't [ __ ] know or you
know maybe i could just be a nicer
[ __ ] person
you know climate change maybe i could
use less i could try to [ __ ] recycle
i could try to you know
pay attention it's going to take
actually individuals getting involved
and and giving a [ __ ]
and stop watching 24-hour news networks
because if we all started doing that
they would then you know through
corporate money start putting out false
stories about how doing that
is eroding at the fiber of this country
um
unbelievable why would you [ __ ] with
puerto rico
you know
beautiful people
beautiful place
i just i just don't understand it
never understand that
why people do the horrible [ __ ]
things that they do but then again i'm
also a [ __ ] so maybe you know
if i actually had political aspirations
i'd be doing the same thing
who knows who knows this is all too
[ __ ] big for my little brain all
right losing weight has lost me clients
wow dear billy freckleflute
i should have made a list of all these
you guys are in the hundreds
of of quality trashings of me and my
name
you know in my orange complexion i'm a
lady listener that makes it even funnier
that a woman wrote that freckle flute
uh i'm a lady listener and need your
wisdom i've been working as a house
cleaner for 10 years
with many long-term regular weekly
clients i have recently lost a lot of
weight
because i got sick of being a fat [ __ ]
lost 55 kilograms
uh but i've noticed since i'm thinner
many of my married female clients have
become less friendly towards me and have
been canceling a lot especially on days
their husbands are at home yeah you know
women just don't get along with each
other man maybe because it's men are
weak i don't know i'm sure it's our
fault
anyway they've never ever complained
about my standard of cleaning and in
fact or maybe you know what maybe it
doesn't have to do with their husbands
maybe they just get mad because you're
going to the gym and they're not
or have the time to i don't know
they've never ever complained about my
standard of cleaning and in fact
have told me how great i am at my job
my personality hasn't changed i'm still
the same person inside in fact my
cleaning has probably improved as i'm so
much fitter and faster now i spit i
suspect it's simply because they see me
as a threat now which is so petty and
upsetting
i can't fill these cancellation spaces
with other jobs as the time slot is
allocated for specific clients who are
regulars every time they cancel it it
cost me income which is extremely
frustrating any advice
you would have would be awesome thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself
um first of all congratulations on
losing weight
okay that's gonna make you live a longer
life so do not
put weight on to work for these [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh i would start having a
cancellation fee
all right
um i would gradually work that in but
the first thing i would do is i would be
out there and i would shop for other
clients
and now that you look the way you look
the first time they meet you
is how you look
all right so [ __ ] these weak people
that aren't happy for you that you've
made a great change in your life
um
you know and one of the one of the great
things about making a positive change in
your life is you really get to see who
your friends are
your friends are the ones that are happy
for you
all right
anybody can be a friend to somebody when
they're
down you know remember that song
nobody knows you when you're down and
out
i don't know there's two sides of that
there's a lot of people that will be
really encouraging when you're down and
out but then when you actually get where
you want to [ __ ] be they can start
acting weird
um
reminds me of a a
a cornerback in the nfl
where he was a complete [ __ ] [ __ ]
when he won
and then when he lost to us he ran up
and he's shaking brady's hands and what
a class act it's like well what the [ __ ]
anybody can do that when you lose
it's how you act when you [ __ ] win
uh
all right boyfriend's cat screams all
the time so what i would do get back to
that i would you need to expand your
business
and get new clients looking the way that
you look and you know what you can
expand your business and then one day
just not have to clean those [ __ ]
jealous [ __ ] house
homes anymore
but good for you congratulations
all right keep doing what you're doing
i'm very happy for you all right
boyfriend's cat screams
all night long all night all that
um screams all night long
hey bill i'm a 30 year old lady listener
who's been dating my boyfriend now for
almost three years
um you're 30 years old you've been
dating for three years what the [ __ ]
going on with that
you know you don't got all day
[ __ ] or get off the pot
uh when we first got together he would
stay over at my place eventually leading
to moving in about a year into our
relationship he moved his cat in as well
oh god you're dating a man that has a
cat
all right
he has had this cat for approximately 10
years and i can understand his
attachment to the fiend his feline
friend yeah that thing's going to live
to be at least 17 years old cats [ __ ]
hang around forever
that said ever since he moved her in
she has proceeded to meow all night long
and this is not your regular cat meow
this is more like a screaming yow like
someone is killing her he's tried
numerous things to try to calm her and
nothing seems to work i personally work
in mental health where my focus and
engagement is critical in working with
people however i have not had a restful
night's sleep for the better part of two
years
and it seems to be getting worse
impacting my abilities at work
what would you do in this situation
signed sleepless in new mexico i [ __ ]
break up with the guy
this guy's choosing his [ __ ] cat over
you [ __ ] this guy
i'd break up with him
i'd say listen either that [ __ ] cat
goes a hugo
you know
why doesn't he pay to get some [ __ ]
cat whisperer to come in there and
figure out what that stupid [ __ ]
thing's problem is
all right i i would give him the option
to do that or i would break up with them
that's what i would do
okay and i would also look at yourself
that what the [ __ ] is wrong with you i
don't mean to be an [ __ ] that you
would put up with this [ __ ] for two
[ __ ] years like like you need to put
a value on yourself
in your night's sleep you know better
part of two months
i can understand two [ __ ] years of
this [ __ ]
i mean i'm not even your situation i
can't even tell you how much i hate that
[ __ ] cat
this [ __ ] guy is choosing that cat
over you
and [ __ ] him
you know
you go the passive aggressive route you
know
start [ __ ] with the cat's food but i
don't want to get into llp to people
with that one uh wife came out as
asexual after 15 years of marriage
dear billy blue balls i've been a fan of
yours since chappelle show days
but new to the podcast
last christmas my wife came out as
asexual
parentheses [ __ ] you 2020.
she said sex has always been a chore
she's not doing it anymore and i can
handle it myself from now on
wow
we talked about options and she doesn't
mind oral a couple times a month
but that didn't last
the last time we had any kind of
intercourse was back in july
on our 15th wedding anniversary she said
i know you're expecting something so
let's get this over with and proceeded
to just lay there
wow
in september i was rubbing her back
and she just turned off her table lamp
and leaned more into it
i pressed my luck and kissed her on the
shoulder she jumped out of bed and slept
on the couch for the next three nights
i gave it another couple days and said
we need to talk she said she felt
sexually assaulted
okay well if i was you i'd go to the
luggage store then pick out myself a
nice set i would [ __ ] fill those
things and i would just
leave she then accused me of being very
selfish because i hadn't checked in on
how she's been feeling since her
revelation
this is true but what is there to check
in on
she seems to have found herself while i
have basically lost an appendage
um
yeah uh she's expecting you to do all of
the [ __ ] work to respect where she is
and she's not even considering the fact
that you just found out that she's been
living alive for 15 [ __ ] years of
your life
and of course you have to con take her
consider into consideration
listen
i don't think there's anything wrong
with trying to put yourself in her shoes
but if she's not going to do it the
other way after she lied to you for 15
years then i you know what are we doing
here
anyways he said i mentioned opening up
our marriage and she just shut that down
because she claims i would be spending
all my free time looking for other women
ignoring our family
she offered me articles about marriage
between sexual and asexual partners and
basically the sexual spouse has to live
as asexual too
which i find to be very one-sided as you
should
as she would
if it was the other way around she says
i can leave at any time and i asked her
if she had really thought
that through and what it would do to the
kids
yeah this seems like a [ __ ]
a loophole to get out of the marriage
we have three kids eleven nine and five
her reply was very matter of fact we've
been married for 10 plus
years so i am entitled to half your
retirement and i'm the primary caregiver
so get out of the house
i'm not gonna lie i could have strangled
her in that moment but i went to for a
walk to cool off
yeah i mean
she's really coming at you with just no
feelings at all
i never thought i would be in this
position considering a separation and
the guilt of what it will do to the kids
is killing me i'm trying not to become
resentful but her my way or the highway
mentality really makes that difficult
obviously i'm not going to force her to
do something she doesn't want to do but
i'm only 42 years old you spent a small
fortune on therapy
let's
i think hear your thoughts on this
i mean
she's a first
ballot hall of fame [ __ ]
to just be honest with you i mean
she has no c the way you're writing this
she has no consideration for your
feelings whatsoever
and is upset with you that you can't
read her mind
she doesn't care
that she's been lying to you for 15
years
she doesn't give a [ __ ]
um about her behavior what it's gonna do
to her kids she's all about herself
and it's not gonna get any better
and it seems like she's gonna be
what does primary caregiver mean
does that mean she makes more money than
you
let me see i gotta get this through
what does
primary
caregiver
mean
it's a person assisting an underage
child or a sick elderly a disabled
relative
any adult can become a primary caregiver
for a relative in need regardless of
education
okay so she's the one taking care of the
kids so
i'm entitled to half your retirement and
this is what happened
okay
she lied to herself for a long time
about who she was
okay
and she went along with what society
said she had to get married and have
kids
and she never wanted to do it
all right
and she made that choice and now she's
blaming you
and she's taking no [ __ ] personal
responsibility for the fact that she
lied to you
and started a family with you and now
you have all of this connection
and in the process of lying to you is
now going to take half of your
retirement
and feels that she deserves that
because she lied to you now here's the
thing
unfortunately she has a vagina which
means she's going to go to court and
she's going to [ __ ] win
so what you have to do
is get the [ __ ] out of this
all right
and all you have to do
is work on
you know maintaining a positive
relationship with your kids never bad
mouth this [ __ ]
okay
never bad mouth or two or kid to your
kids all right they when they get older
they're gonna figure out
who she is
okay
and
you know i don't know is she entitled to
half your retirement
i don't know about that i have no idea
but i know your kids are eleven nine and
five
so you're gonna have to pay child
support
for the next 13 years and you're just
gonna have to man up and just realize
that that's what you're gonna have to do
okay
and she can take your half your
retirement and she can take the house
and she can do all of that [ __ ] but she
can't take your happiness unless you let
her
and you can go out there as a 42 year
old
all right
and go out there and you can find a
woman that actually is is deserves you
because this woman doesn't
and i'm sorry that this happened to you
and you know
i don't know the only empathy i can have
for this woman is maybe you know society
looks down on asexual people so she felt
she had to do this thing i don't know
but the fact that she's [ __ ] angry at
you
is ridiculous she owes you an apology
um unless you know you're some
overbearing son of a [ __ ] and i mean i
can't tell that in your email i have no
[ __ ] idea but if you're just being a
husband and you're thinking she's loving
you and enjoying having sex with you
um
i don't
know i'm not even convinced that she's
[ __ ] asexual
okay
maybe she is but you know when you
[ __ ] get out of this thing if you
decide to because you know
i'm not an expert on this [ __ ] i'm just
[ __ ] get this is just bar room
[ __ ] advice
all right brace yourself that there's
another guy
there's a possibility of that but what
you are in the way you have described it
is unfucking winnable
you know like when you just a team just
realized like we're not going to win a
championship this year and they just
dump all their stars this is what you
got to do you just got to pack it in you
ain't winning the title this year
but um
you know
is is
plenty of time
to turn this whole [ __ ] thing around
and um
if you just really work on that
and like i said stay positive with the
kids and never bad mouth your ex
you know you can turn this whole thing
around and then it just becomes a funny
story
and i got to be honest with you here's
here's a positive thing who the [ __ ] is
gonna top this story in a bar
when guys start telling that oh i dated
this chick she [ __ ] did this and that
oh yeah
i was married for 15 years my wife out
of nowhere told me she was asexual
and [ __ ] you know
i went to kiss her shoulder and she
accused me of sexual assault
and then said she was entitled to half
my retirement
then she's gonna take the [ __ ] house
i'm sure you could tell it in a funnier
way
um
yeah i mean i would just i don't know
i feel for you man that's [ __ ]
terrible
that's [ __ ] terrible man it's you
know
it's just so much [ __ ] people go through
that woman she loses weight she looks
good she feels good about herself and
then people stop [ __ ] using her
because they can't [ __ ] handle that
she's in shape
i swear to god man
i swear to god every time i start to
turn the corner and i start to think
positive about life and people you know
you guys write in you send me these
[ __ ] stories i just don't get it i
don't know maybe because i sat there i
watched [ __ ] 27 innings of people
going
i'm just like
i don't know maybe put me in a [ __ ]
mood i have no idea but anyways happy
halloween i hope you guys had a great
halloween i hope you have a great
november right the holiday season has
started really try to pay attention to
it it always goes by nice and quick
thanksgiving's coming up next
and uh you know
don't invite any [ __ ] over
you know
just trying to enjoy a nice day of just
sitting down and [ __ ] eating or
whatever
oh by the way i didn't bring up the new
england patriots man they beat the
[ __ ] charges again we just [ __ ]
i don't know you'd think tom maybe i did
bring that up i can't remember i'm so
[ __ ] tired um
i gotta be honest with you
watching that game
okay
and watching our qb there
and watching bill belichick adjusting to
him and watching him kind of you know
getting on the same page and seeing how
our defense is playing the little bit
that i saw as you can tell
i don't know the mac jones at risk
i think i i have very
i'm liking it the only thing i don't
like is how old bill belichick is but i
i just you know
we are a very solid
football team and i feel we are way
better
in november than we you know than we
were in the end of october i should say
than we were in september
and
uh
i know what that means
with bill belichick teams and i am
excited for the future all right anyway
that is the podcast
and uh
yeah
and that's it you guys put value on
yourself and in your time and don't let
people treat you like [ __ ] like that
and stay in [ __ ] relationships don't
do that [ __ ] don't [ __ ] do that just
move on same thing like friendships i'm
telling you
you get to a certain point in life
you know some people get there way
quicker than i did and it's just you
just really like if somebody is work
if they have [ __ ] work just it's it
it's over
you already have a job
you're hanging out with friends it
should be easy
you know
if it's [ __ ] work if you got to think
like well i want to say this but if i
say that then i'm going to deal with
this yeah
get out of that
get out of that [ __ ] all right okay
that's it happy halloween to you guys
and uh enjoy your week
and i will check in on you
on thursday
you